superhero movies are a staple of modern
cinema but their road to mainstream
popularity wasn't always smooth for
decades most attempts to bring comics to
life have either flopped or were met
with total indifference here are a few
superhero movies that you've probably
never seen if you're not familiar with
the superheroes of Valiant Comics all
you really need to know is that they
mostly create characters by mashing
other iconic characters together XO Man
O'War for instance is essentially Conan
the Barbarian with a suit of Iron Man
armor bloodshot is Arnie from predator
mixed with Arnie from the Terminator and
ninh Jack's is pretty much a crossover a
Batman in James Bond which is exactly as
awesome as it sounds in 2018 Valiant
decided to try bringing their characters
to the big screen originally released as
a web series a few years earlier
nin Jack versus the valiant universe did
exactly what it says on the tin fitting
superspy ninja Colin King against the
live-action version of his entire comic
book universe
unlike most obscure comic book movies
however this one's actually worth
watching if only for the cast pro
wrestler John Hennigan plays the eternal
warrior while bloodshot is played by
former Power Ranger Jason David Frank
the debate over which swamp monster is
better has been raging ever since DC's
Swamp Thing and Marvel's Man Thing first
debuted within three months of each
other way back in 1971 when it comes to
their adventures outside of comics
though there's no question about who got
the better end of the deal Swamp Thing
is starred in a live-action TV series
our cartoon for kids to movies and a
streaming series that while short-lived
was extremely well received Man Thing
however had a movie that made 3 percent
of its budget and its international
theatrical release and went straight to
cable in America it's also primarily
remembered for featuring a cast of
Australian actors attempted to perform
Louisiana accents to varying degrees of
success
what no offense but well I just expected
someone more famous the movie does have
a few good points though Man Thing
himself has a pretty cool design
especially when your expectations are
adjusted for a low-budget sci-fi
original from 15 years ago
unfortunately all of the weirdness that
makes man things so interesting in the
comics are ditched in favor of a fairly
generic slasher where man thing is
abstence ibly portrayed as the bad
there have actually been two movies
based on the spirit will eisenerz
groundbreaking Golden Age comic strip
the first was a 1987 TV movie starring
Sam Jay Jones whose previous comic strip
adaptation Flash Gordon became a cult
classic thanks largely to its lavish kam
penis and killer soundtrack by Queen the
Spirit was meant as a pilot of a TV
series but it failed to get the radians
that were needed to convince anyone that
a full series would be a good idea the
2008 spirit film on the other hand
failed at literally everything it was
written and directed by Frank Miller and
star Gabriel mocked in the title role
opposite samuel l.jackson as his
arch-nemesis the octopus if miller's
name sounds familiar that's because he's
the groundbreaking creator responsible
for the Dark Knight Returns and Batman
year one two of the most highly regarded
Batman comics of all time Miller
approached the spirit the same way that
he and Robert Rodriguez had approached
their movie adaptation of Miller's own
over-the-top noir comics Sin City right
down to the high contrast visuals
ridiculous dialogue and goofy comedy
violence the problem or one of them at
least was that the only thing Eisner
style and Miller style had in common was
that they were both technically comic
books the end result was a film that is
arguably the single worst comic-book
adaptation of all time yes even worse
than whichever one you're currently
thinking of it makes Corman's Fantastic
Four look like Captain America Civil War
and makes Batman and Robin look like
Batman unsurprisingly the spirit tanked
at the box office it's probably not a
coincidence that macht hasn't done much
movie work since no Comics franchise
embodies the 90s quite as much as the
x-men at the height of the decade there
were about 17 X related comics hitting
the shelves every month and the one that
best captured the spirit of the era was
probably Generation X as the name
implies it was focused on a group of
younger mutants led by established fan
favorite Jubilee who formed the new
class of disaffected teenagers at Xavier
school based on that description it
probably seems like the perfect
franchise to adapt into a movie in fact
the producers hoped it would serve as a
pilot for an eventual TV show it
probably would have to with the
Generation X movie had happened under
literally any other circumstances
sadly pretty much everything was stacked
against it for one thing its release
coincided with the collapse of the
comics industry and while
Generation X comics were genuinely good
and had hordes of dedicated fans it just
wasn't the time to be launching a TV
series even if it had lured in the
comics audience though there were
choices made that seemed designed to
alienate bands such as casting a white
actress to play Jubilee one of Marvel's
most prominent Asian American characters
also instead of using an established
supervillain former Max Headroom actor
Matt Frewer played a generic weirdo mad
scientist of course it didn't help that
it was also just generally awful in
addition to looking like it was filmed
entirely in a laser tag arena the
effects were terrible even by the
standards of a 1996 TV movie and as for
the performances but everything I said I
could do I've done and now you're a
sitting millionaire here's hoping that
Gen X's predecessor New Mutants has
better luck when it's movie adaptation
comes out assuming it ever does hey wait
a second Justice League isn't an obscure
movie at all it was a worldwide hit that
made over 650 million dollars at the box
office led by a cast of household names
sitting at the heart of a massive shared
universe except of course this isn't
that one no this is Justice League of
America the unaired in America 1997 TV
pilot that nobody saw and even fewer
people liked it's hard to understand why
though after all it's the Justice League
it even features everyone's favorite DC
characters such as Guy Gardner ice and
the Martian Manhunter
yeah so rather than using the classic
lineup of characters like Superman
Batman and Wonder Woman this Justice
League was based on the late 80s Justice
League international comics where the
team was reimagined as something more
like a sitcom fronted by a roster of
third stringers and honestly if that's
not a bad idea
JLI was the source of some of the best
DC comics of its era and the lower
stakes adventures of characters like
Blue Beetle and Booster Gold were
undoubtedly far easier to produce on a
TV budget even the set up for the show
seems like it's ahead of its time
intercutting the same kind of
first-person interview segments with the
comedy the same way that the office and
Parks and Rec would years later of
course that setup only really works if
the writing is any good the writing in
Justice League of America was not
believe it or not the Marvel Cinematic
Universe wasn't the first time that two
of Marvel's most famous heroes got
together for a live-action adventure
it's
that honor goes to the Incredible Hulk
returns a 1988 TV movie in which the
Incredible Hulk returns ok not the best
title in the world but Hank you can't
win them all released in 1988 as a
continuation of the Incredible Hulk TV
show this TV movie was supposed to be
just like a classic comic book team-up
between The Hulk and the god of thunder
but thor ragnarok this ain't if nothing
else it has exactly the level of
special-effects that you'd expect from a
show where the main technical
achievement was finding a large man
giving him a pair of jorts and painting
him green like the comics store has been
cast out of asgaard and mystically
bonded with Don Blake but in this
version Blake doesn't turn back into
Thor here he just sort of stands around
providing play-by-play commentary while
Thor hits things presumably because
someone wanted Thor and Blake to
interact with each other and forge a
buddy comedy dynamic that they could use
to sell a Thor TV show it never happened
if the Incredible Hulk Returns had a
title that was a little too literal its
sequel had one that was an outright lie
not only did trial of the Incredible
Hulk not feature the Hulk being put on
trial it didn't feature any trial at all
there is a single courtroom scene when
Bruce Banner flips out and turns into
his alter-ego
a scene featuring Stan Lee in his first
Marvel cameo no less
but even that happens in a dream
sequence what it does have in keeping
with its legal themes is a team-up with
blind lawyer and part-time super ninja
vigilante Matt Murdock that was meant to
be a backdoor pilot for a daredevil
series while that never happened there
actually is some fun daredevil stuff in
here including the casting of John
rhys-davies as the kingpin and yes like
the 2015 daredevil series this one
features a hallway fight it's not quite
as brutal though if you ever find
yourself wondering how hot comics were
in the early 90s consider this back then
live-action superhero movies were
produced in order to promote comics
rather than the other way around well
one was anyway 1993 firearm released
exclusively on a VHS tape that came with
the number 0 issue of the comic of the
same name okay so movie might be pushing
it this thing clocks in at just over
half an hour if you count the
supplementary two-minute promo for the
rest of the ultraverse comics while the
movie is of the quality you'd expect for
a low-budget VHS short film the comic
itself wasn't bad for its abbreviated
both the film and the comic were written
by James Robinson who would go on to
write the comic Starman which is finally
remembered as a true classic of its era
and the movie adaptation of League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen which definitely
isn't take a moment and imagine the Nick
Fury of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
he's the cool no-nonsense superspy who
stepped out of the shadows in 2008 to
reveal that there was more to iron man's
world than just Tony Stark
he's the stern commander who brought the
team together in the Avengers he's the
toughest nails badass who made his
shocking return from the dead in Captain
America the Winter Soldier now imagine
that instead of samuel l.jackson that
same character was played by David
Hasselhoff but it happened believe it or
not in 1998 as part of another ill-fated
attempt to make a TV movie based on a
Marvel character who admittedly
originally kind of looked like
Hasselhoff anyway in the hopes of
eventually launching a series shockingly
it didn't work although the movie is at
least a little watchable for a cheer
absurdity MCU fans will undoubtedly know
Stanley is the friendly face of the
Marvel Universe he's the guy who
co-created spider-man the x-men and the
Avengers and left behind a towering
legacy in pop culture and no doubt all
of that is true today on the man's later
career however was a little rocky ER in
the 2000s he tended to attach his name
to basically any project he could
regardless of how involved he had been
with them case in point 2006 s
Lightspeed which features a character
who can be generously filed under the
heading of Stan's lesser creations the
premise is an architectural marvel
constructed entirely from cliches a guy
named Daniel light gets speed powers
becomes a costumed hero and fights a big
Python man named Python it's not even
interesting in its terribleness except
for the hilarity of the difference in
how light speed looks on his
straight-to-video Fox arts and the way
he looks in the actual movie talk about
liberties check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]